for some people you know for you it may
be so it's one of those things I just it
shuts down a dialogue where if
Christians say it's a choice I don't
think anyone chews up and said you know
what wakes up and says hmm I think today
I'm gonna like the Wiener this is
something it's controversial now fun dip
Dan is very liberal on the socialist
seat on some of the social issues
pro-pro gay guy likes the gays
personally would engage in relations
with transgender men know women and used
to be fellas it's it's one thing I see a
lot I see a lot of Christians well there
are a lot of arguments made against
Christians let's put it that way
where they think you choose to be gay
and there are some Christians who say oh
I believe it's a choice now I'm I'm a
Christian full disclosure I talk about
that I'm open about it but I I don't
fully understand now I understand
obviously everyone has you can choose
your sexual actions you can choose your
sexual behavior you can choose whether
you're faithful to your wife or not you
can choose whether you have sex before
marriage or not everyone has a choice
over their sexual actions and that's the
endgame and if you believe certain
sexual actions to be immoral great
that's your right I have opinions on on
those matters too but to say that you
choose to be gay and I'll even upset
some some Christian friends and and even
probably some members of my family I I
never bought that and the more I read my
Bible and the more I I'm trying to be
careful but let me just not be careful
the more I read my Bible I don't see any
justification for that I think
Christians say well it's a choice
because right it's wrong they believe
it's sexually immoral homosexuality okay
let's let's assume we're both even on
board with that premise so they say it's
a choice because God wouldn't make you
that God wouldn't make you wouldn't be
born gay now the science this idea
there's a gay gene and stuff I mean they
just try and throw out these blanket
terms that's also inaccurate so you do
you choose to be gay God wouldn't make
you born that
well that assumes that everyone is
either born perfect and you get into the
concept of original sin or that everyone
is naturally perfect which is of course
untrue just like it their basis of
saying God wouldn't make you born gay
and make you have an affliction that
that you couldn't kick okay well a lot
of the people saying that are sleeping
around with women who aren't their wives
or they're cheating on their wives or
they're watching pornography did God
make you that way
or did you make you that way you didn't
choose to want to fornicate with
everything that moves as a man that's
just part of your biological hardwiring
it's your affliction to deal with it's
your job to handle it now the choice
comes in and in how you deal with those
instincts and how you deal with your
proclivities for example I have a
proclivity toward getting frustrated I
have a I have a short temper God didn't
God wouldn't make you that's your choice
that's my choice in how I deal with it
it's not my choice in how my brain works
so I don't see and you can let me know
comment tweet me at s Crowder any kind
of a Christian argument that somehow
someone having a proclivity toward being
gay is more of a choice than someone
having a proclivity toward wanting to be
promiscuous or toward wanting to consume
you know inappropriate amounts of
alcohol we all have proclivities towards
sin it doesn't mean that God put that on
us but through circumstance people have
different properties or gluttony it's
totally not my fault right exactly you
were just born that way
well yeah you were born now you can
choose how you deal with it but I don't
have a problem with that I know that I
don't have a problem with I mean I
overeat probably more than most people
but it's it's not my
burden to bear for some people you know
for you it may be so it's one of those
things I just it shuts down a dialogue
where if Christians say it's a choice I
don't think anyone choose up and said
you know wakes up and says hmm I think
today I'm gonna like the Wiener I don't
that happens and I've had friends who
were clearly gay when they were young
but there was no doubt about it they
were raised in Christian conservative
households and they were just clearly
very feminine and gay now it doesn't
mean that it's not necessarily I don't
want to go double negative it doesn't
mean that it's moral now wait you can
have that debate I'm not going to have
that debate right now it doesn't mean
it's moral for him to go out and sleep
with dudes you can still say well we
believe that to be immoral many
religions do some people don't so
separate that issue from the idea that
you're you're just you're just making a
choice to be gay and by the way in that
same breath liberals need to stop saying
that people are born that way and they
have no choice over their sexual actions
I have friends who are gay who don't
want to be gay or they feel they feel
they can change it and so they go and
and they've gone to counseling whether
you believe it's effective or not they
personally are not comfortable with the
lifestyle and they want to change their
lifestyle and then liberals attack them
and say you're just being guilted into
it no some of these people just aren't
comfortable being gay and they they'd
like to change it about themselves if
you're gonna say it's a choice or it's
not it let them make their choice let
any of these people make their choice on
again choosing your sexual behavior
anyway it's just something I feel like
you're yeah go ahead fund him no I was
just saying you have one minute left
okay but I bet you that stuff that
probably you know surprised you because
you've talked about that with Christians
yeah a lot of people think that it it is
a choice and I think yeah you're born
that way but yeah you choose to act on
it but I'd hate to see anybody left
alone left without love that's the part
that bothers me
I don't want anybody to not have the
ability to find someone to love and
share their life with now that wasn't
when I was getting at my point was I
can't see any biblical backing to say
all of a sudden that's a choice because
that's the sin where it's a choice and
and everything else is you know it's
just circumstance and you deal with it
let's just be accurate let's just be
consistent with that and of course the
most important consistency is loving the
people I'm not necessarily accepting
what you view to be the sin louder with
Crowder we'll be back after this if you
like this video subscribe by clicking my
face and if you hated it well join the
club and you're gonna hate this next
video right next to me but doesn't a
part of you know what it is